Darth Vader has stood the test of time
is one of the greatest villains in movie
history yet for all the Star Wars
baddies Fame and popularity Disney
doesn't seem to have any intention of
giving Darth Vader his own movie despite
mining Star Wars lore for all sorts of
other spin-offs and prequels why here's
a look at some of the reasons Disney
won't give Darth Vader his own movie
been there done that so far Disney
standalone Star Wars spin-offs have been
prequels that fill in gaps in franchise
history
rogue one explained how the rebellion
got the death star plans in a new hope
while solo explores the early life of
everyone's favorite scruffy nerf-herder
but there's not all that much left to
tell about Darth Vader's past because
the prequels went into great detail
about exactly how and why Anakin
Skywalker grew up to become Darth Vader
even the gap between the prequels in the
original trilogy has been filled in some
thanks to shows like Star Wars rebels
and even if they wanted to revisit
Vader's early days there's one big
problem Anakin Skywalker ruined Darth
Vader few things killed the mystique
into aww associated with a legendary
villain like seeing him as a love
stricken whiny teenage breath sure it
made some sense that Anakin had anger
issues he did fall to the dark side
after all but while the journey of
Anakin to Vader could and should have
been compelling the actual story
on-screen was anything but on the plus
side thanks to his burned up body being
forever locked away in a robotic suit
Darth Vader never had to worry about
feeling sand ever again but the prequels
also killed fan interest in seen Anakin
ever again
a little bit goes a long way remember
all those other Star Wars projects we
mentioned well they're set early enough
for Darth Vader to be an active villain
allowing for plenty of cool moments like
his scene-stealing cameo in rogue one
and if there's one thing the prequels
taught everyone it's that Vader actually
works best in small doses if you look at
the original trilogy Vader actually
doesn't appear on screen very much for
example it's estimated that he only
appears in 12 minutes of a new hope with
Vader less is more and the looming
threat of him appearing makes his
eventual appearance all the scarier a
full-length Vader spotlight film would
go against decades of tradition while
also working against the characters
strengths after all as we learned from
the prequels familiarity breeds can
temped so for now fans will have to
settle for Darth Vader being used as a
plot device to drive other stories and
that's probably for the best
the rise of other Star Wars villains
while films like solo seem designed to
mine Star Wars nostalgia that nostalgia
can only take you so far which is why
movies like the last Jedi have worked so
hard to break from tradition and
establish something new and different
while Vader might be iconic he also now
belongs to the past and with Disney
working to establish new villains in the
films like kylo Ren Captain phasma and
general Hux
not to mention new villains in the
comics like the morally ambiguous dr.
Aphra putting the spotlight back on the
previous generation of villains like
Darth Vader seems counterproductive
James Earl Jones as much as we love
James Earl Jones as Darth Vader we have
to face reality he won't be around
forever and does anybody really want to
see a Darth Vader film where Vader is
voiced by anyone except Jones with Jones
now in his late 80s and no Vader film
currently in development it's very
possible that Disney may decide out of
respect for Jones and his fans to
squelch any future plans for a vader
solo film I have one thing to say to
people like you I like Star Wars - the
past is the future is the past let's
face it
Hollywood is a reboot happy place the
odds favor currently popular franchises
being remade within a decade or two so
could the much reviled Star Wars
prequels get a complete overhaul - think
about it no poorly acted petulant Anakin
Skywalker no Jar Jar Binks and no
midi-chlorians nope none of it ever
happened wiping the slate clean and
rebooting the prequels by replacing them
with a Vader Solo franchise might be the
best chance the character has at getting
his own film and fixing the mistakes of
the past at the same time thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Applause]
[Music]